with your forecast and ted we're seeing
some of that fire
that we talked about any impact on air
quality as we take a look yeah right now
looks like air quality is still good but
you can see some of that smoke starting
to
peak its way over to our area so we will
double check
on that i have some info on that fire
too big bright sandy valley road and
highway 160
is where this is located on the other
side of the spring mountains of course
the fire has grown to an estimated 200
to 300
acres and has extended to the trees and
that's the reason why we're
producing that big volume of smoke that
we're seeing up there on the screen
bureau of land management blm and the
forest service are on location helping
with containment and we just found out
as a precaution campers and boy scout
troops are being evacuated
of course from that area with good
reason there are no reports of
structures
in danger at this time and of course
there is no
cause to that fire as uh yet we'll be
tracking this we're sending a reporter
out there to also
track that too and we'll have updates on
that continuously
on social media there too but you can
see that smoke really coming up there
now also we're tracking those winds
those winds certainly not helping
because we still see those winds between
10 to 20 miles per hour on the spine of
the mountains
and also on the back side of the
mountain there too so again we'll be
watching that